what's the oldest you would date oldest
like realistically date for marriage
purposes like real dating
um it's weird because i'm 29 now so i
could date older
david i'm 25.
25 is
i have to see are you hot
you've already met david you haven't
thought twice about him but he is
hilarious and he smells really good
smells amazing funny funny by the way
shout out to david everybody who watches
the south cast knows david he should
have been here today but he's on behind
the scenes we love david anyway oldest
you would date
and for david's sake what's the youngest
you would date i need numbers now not
not thoughts well
i was in um
london and
hit it off with a 19 year old i did not
know he was 19.
did he did he act older than he was i
mean he bought me
did you help him with his homework
what'd you do
yeah send me the assignments babe i got
you no i'm just kidding can i hold your
book so uh clearly
19 is the youngest you didn't know did
you have to like i didn't hook up with
him but i so what the hell are we
talking about here i was like interested
in him and you were his tutor and there
was a possibility okay not a probability
open-minded to it he must have been very
smooth hello madame
how are you doing a baguette we lost an
accent
what's the oldest you would date
victoria i
would say i would go up to like 40
one
okay well it's weird because no offense
but yeah like you're 41 so it's like
guys that
everyone's older now that i'm 29. so i
feel like i could go it's weird
yeah i think 50 year olds okay so we
just went from 41 to 50. rebecca i
wouldn't do 60. okay that's your cutoff
rebecca what is the oldest that you
would date and what's the youngest you
would date how old are you he's 41. all
right
everybody wants to date you man i don't
know hey you know what it was it was the
statistics that we brought up on the
point
thank you
right now
my favorite guy ever
people wear their age differently
and so
i'm trying to think of numbers to attach
because i don't
yeah do this really yeah age is just a
number
truly
um
okay i'm going to say the oldest that i
would date is
125 because i would like to cover all
the ground just in case there's
something i missed i like options okay
so you would date a 90 year old guys
what you're saying likely no but i just
like to leave it on the table
realistically would you date a 60 year
old
obviously we're talking someone who's
got their [ __ ] together he's in shape he
looks good actually i did date a
six-year-old that's all happened
very wealthy man who was 74 years old he
would probably love you
yeah
okay so like
would you date a 60 year old yes or no
um
it's not really the age that is
i know you're trying to make these
questions i just you know it's it's not
the age it's um sort of how the person
is in certain aspects of their life
would you date a hot ass successful 60
year old
yeah okay perfect
oh yeah would you date a very attractive
possibly french 19 year old
for a short period of time
you